If you're using the movie render queue, however, this allows us to add multiple sequences so we can customize the output settings essentially.
So you have two different settings here.
You've got the render local, which will render locally and the same way the Unreal Engine and similar to how plain editor would work.
If you want to render remotely, however, this is more resource intensive and does not run the editor's code.
So projects must be saved to do that.
So the two options are at the bottom here, whether you choose to render local or render remote.
And there's additional documentation if you need to know more about both of those options.
You can also customize the render settings, whether it be project wide or even shot by shot.
So you can select and add the render settings, the export file types and render output options.
And you can create some render presets so you can share those presets across the team.
You can just share them across different projects if you want.
And it's a really nice, efficient way of working to get consistent quality output either across many shots in the projects or even across many different projects.
And the movie render queue currently supports anti-aliasing and the burn in, whether default or custom.
We've got camera shutter control.
You can edit the console variables and the movie render queue will take into account any console variables you've set, which again, we've got some tips for later in the slides here.
We've got some game overrides that you can do.
You've got the high resolution output, which the previous render option didn't have.
So you've got tile count, which are image breaks, overlap ratio and texture sharpness bias.
And we also support ray tracing and lumen with the movie render queue.
Which is a great handy feature to have.
So the high quality media export user benefits are virtual production is high quality anti-aliasing and motion blur.
On the gaming side, you've got higher quality cinematics with less artifacting from motion blur and temporal anti-aliasing.
For the automotive side, you might have the temporal supersampling, rotational motion blur, high resolution tiling for larger image output.
And on the archviz side, you've got spatial supersampling for anti-aliased image with little ray tracing noise.